beh ragazzi prevedere questo nuovissimo
video io sono pari dei diciott'anni su
the binding of isaac giocato su nintendo
switch sulla postazione dal computer con
joystick della playstation 5 già non si
capisce una sega e abbiamo appena
cominciato
quelle che vedete in alto a sinistra
sono tutte le icone di tutti i post di
isaac che io ho fatto quasi tutti in
modalità normale tranne dell'oste che
non si può farlo me ne mancano veramente
pochi e con the forgotten ragazzi per
farli the forgotten me ne mancano
quattro tra cui la grid che però non
posso farla in questo video
ma le altre tre che sono tre boss
fortissimi di isaac sono satana belen e
mega satana
voglio provare a farle in questo video
non so se riesco effettivamente perché
un generali sa che lo gioco per i cazzi
miei però è probabile che io riesca
quale in questo video no non è probabile
non riuscivo a fare una sega
ma proviamoci alla ragazzi prima cosa
devo fare in isaac e bill dare il
personaggio però che molti di voi
sappiano come si gioca ad isaac anche se
effettivamente non è pochissimo lo è
diventato veramente molto di più negli
ultimi anni ok ripartiamo da zero ma
schifo soggetto giusto personaggio qua
che può dare le mazzate così o staccarsi
e spara le lacrime molto carina come
cosa quindi o un volo limitato comunque
non vi sto a spiegare come funziona
isaac perché sono diventiamo scemi
quindi io do per scontato dove sappiate
cosa voglia dire giocare ad aism questa
è un americano kid fa veramente si è
praticamente finché non manila la gente
loro non ti vedono teoricamente non
vorrei dire una cagata ma è così quindi
entro in una stanza e nessuno se c'è un
nemico che non c'è neanche un nemico non
ci sono stanze con i vostri averi
comincia lega perché fa tutto cagare o
questa questa è già una buona parte
rispetto a prima è 10 volte va bene
facciamo un passo in avanti direttamente
al boss che è meglio a light bene già il
danno a caso abbiamo preso perfetto un
altro caso
eccoci beh meno male visto che vi a
trigoria ma allora speriamo di trovare
il roba buona per la partenza non è male
comunque lui poi lanciarlo anche l'osso
sacro da una figata
sto gioco comunque ragazzi incredibile
perché molti non al primo secolo non ha
mai visto sto gioco
la neuro ma se vi assicuro che è uno dei
giochi più belli che aver giocato negli
ultimi cinque anni almeno
no ragazzi non avete idea ho trovato
ciclope che è uno degli oggetti più
potenti di tutto il gioco perché mi
aumenta il danno perché il danno è a
sinistra adesso devo 24 e rarissimo
trovarlo e rarissimo e rarissimo ragazze
rarissimo che uno pazzesco
no non ciclope polifemo scusatemi
sbagliato o ciclope polifemo
praticamente sparo una volta ogni morte
di papa però almeno levo tantissimo e o
un osso o un osso gigante quindi sono
figo per fare bega satana devo trovare
la sacrifices la sacrifices room vi
permette di evocare gli angeli ma è
difficilissimo farla per un motivo
perché devi sacrificare i cuori tutti
quelli che hai sostanzialmente e non è
mai una bella cosa ve lo assicuro allora
ci siamo ragazzi carico già il colpo
perché appena entro glielo tiro in
faccia che è quello di prima era posti
più di mate però lasciato perdere perché
non avevo trovato una mazza fan e
sciocca tutto starà nono la vita nel
culo nega non avete idea allora devo
stare attento con satana ragazzi perché
satana che si è aperta la porta se
prendo un oggetto da satana poi non non
può non mi evoca gli angeli quindi
questo non lo posso fare teoricamente
perché se non riesco a prenderla
geografia non lo prendo questo oggetto
che ha partenza erano tre cuori quindi
con calze lo prendevo uguale gli oggetti
vista tra sono molto forti in cambio dei
cuori però il problema è che se lo
prendono non mi evoca l'angelo quindi
non lo posso fare
let's go tra black room è una runa che
ti permette di avere un effetto casuale
l'unico che non mi andava bene rai era
quando diventò uno spettro al mio corpo
mi pare colpi quindi è una cosa
utilissima il suo gioco ragazzi madonna
ciclobus è fortissimo comunque se riesco
aumentarmi la velocità di attacco sony
vincibile comunque ragazzi queste sono
le figu del games è uno dei piani più
difficili di tutto isaac con rapportato
all
il fatto che siamo all'inizio della
partita non so cosa io allora mi
prendere il cuore perché con il cuore
raga riesco a farmi la sacrifices se
dopo serve perché più cori o pilipo fine
posso sprecare per utilizzare la sacra
oggetto ti prego la roba buona non si
capisce cos'è
quanto odio stack urss ragazzi non si
capisce quali sono gli oggetti lo devo
prendere a caso non male non malissimo
non mi ricordo cosa fa però normalissimo
madonna questo qua ragazzi questo
ragazzi e quella era quello di prima
solo da adulto e grosso come la morte
aspetta da una morte più grossa vedeva
attirato ecco perche i mad o non mi ha
preso da yahoo
hp up va bene dai dai allora posso fare
la sacrifices non mi è uscito ancora un
angelo quindi sfiga prove ci sta mi
conviene andare prima fare il boss per
vedere se mi esce l'angelo perché se mi
esce l'angelo potrei anche evitare di
farla sai perché mi toglie un sacco di
quel porco demonio ok con questa chiave
che ho preso possa aprire qualsiasi cosa
senza spendere chiavi va bene questa è
la donation machine che non è male
perché possa aumentare le probabilità
che minsk all angelo nomis inceppata
perfetto va bene ragazzi faccio il boss
vediamo se mi esce l'angelo se non mi
esce vado a prendermi è uscito mi è
uscito raga riuscito che è più che che
allora prendo questo allora l'oggetto è
una merda perché le oggettive l'angelo
sono fortissimi tranne questo che una
merda lo faccio fuori e teoricamente non
mi serve fare la sacrifices perché ne me
ne servono due per fare sta beccando me
ne servono due per fare per appena avere
la chiave di mega satana perché lui tira
un solo pezzo di chiave che questo viene
serve a me ne serve un altro larga
quindi non so se farà lo stesso sacri ma
porca
io la faccio ragala faccio uguale la
faccio uguale perché sono pieno di cuori
dai la posso fare
ok ragazzi ci siamo praticamente
arrivati da schiacciare un'altra volta
l'oggetto angelico cielo che questo che
non è male
a sfruttare l'angelo no scusate mi dopo
porca ma preso e ora dove dovrebbe
spuntare adesso perfetto non stare
attenta a non morire ai ragazzi perché
qua è molto difficile perché la zona è
piccola quindi è molto facile schiattare
meno male che questa fare male perché
questo affare valente proiettili meno
male dai ce l'ho fatta ok ho tutti i
pezzi o la parola chiave completa per
fare per aprire la porta di mega satana
è molto difficile averla ragazzi non è
andata male inc già incredibile i suoi
al divino qua allora adesso prendo
questo e se riesco a riprendermi il
cuore non è male non riesco a riprendono
i loro cari
quindi niente usciamo l'abbiamo fatta
allora non ho speso neanche tanti cuori
perché il fatto che io riesca intervalla
intervallare lì tra un personaggio
all'altro è ottima come cosa quindi sì
alla fine non sprecati 3 però ho un
oggetto a gerico fortissimo è il tap che
culo e rage downer avere almeno uno
positivo ma vaffan cuore io li odio
questi li ho sempre odiati da non
fastidio del cribbio
che fastidio mi danno non avete idea
quei ragazzi mi incazzo per chi non
conoscesse isaac e prendere un danno e
tanto piano soldi mi servono soldi e non
soldi e non ho una bomba per poter fare
esplodere cose che mi danno soldi
a meno che non merita chi il boss non ho
modo di fare soldi quindi niente questo
è un bene jap e quello è un angelo
quindi potevo anche non fare la
sacrifices trovato un oggetto quindi
sticazzi vediamo cosa vita di oggetto ti
prego qualcosa di buono come qualcosa di
botti prego lo ripeto non è male non è
male non è male non mentono alimento la
loro ogni istanza ti permette di
prendere un colpo gratis quindi ogni
stanza possono darvi una botta gratis
non pensate male non mi fanno danno
quindi niente male l'oggetto più potente
dell'angelo e un cuore rosso che
moltiplica il danno fai un danno che non
esiste perché sono troppo casato perché
è una bellissima
ok non essere abbastanza gatto perché
non è il motivo caro the sun però non ci
serve adesso porca vacca suo personaggio
c'è un problema ogni volta che gli
scende un cuore scompare quindi non mi
serve niente avere robe del genere le
sanati cura totalmente però non senso
capito ho trovato abbastanza fuori però
sai li ho trovati sai che ti dico lo
faccio
noi siamo necropolis due c'è mamma
quindi non posso assolutamente andare da
mamma ok di nuovo la sacrifices
ragazzino cosa esce ok mi ha buttato da
un angelo no ha menato ma me ne vado non
posso andarmene barco demonio prendo
perdo un cuore qua sicuro ho usato the
sun per curarmi quel cuore la perché lo
perdevo sicuro 100 100 invece non lo
perdevo potevo anche non bene cosa fa
poi cosa che ho trovato blu noi da the
va fermato perfetto troppo vinto ragazzi
momento ho vinto tutto
tutto vito ve lo assicuro non c'è roba
migliore di quella che ho trovato non
esiste deve aver praticamente ti ha una
certa il danno diventa doppio la gente
ti leva un cuore da dopo che bhatti
mamma e adesso non mi leva un cuore mi
dava sempre mezzo cuore è veramente
praticamente vinta cioè non so come
potrei perdere saranno persa sicura
ok non mi vedo il personaggio manco io
c'è perché c'è sto trincati che mi
nasconde però non mi vedo manco io vado
addosso alla gente easy ok
devo aumentare assolutamente il mio la
mia velocità di sparo da che c'è di di
mazzate perché vado troppo lenta però
devo una falcata pure l'angelo che però
ha già preso quindi non serve a niente
allora cosa polaroid nera
andiamo all'angelo ma non serve più a
nulla perché l'ho già fatto e vi direi
che possiamo andare al 2 dall ass
ragazzine da molto più difficile però
l'alimento il the waters leva un sacco e
teoricamente dovrei farcela
i ragazzi ci siamo al piano del cuore di
mamma se cercano di fare tutto
abbastanza in fretta perché sono
abbastanza il dato quindi non ha senso
che vada troppo in giro però le segrete
si fanno male
non male non male entrato non so come
funzioni con the forgotten perché mente
quando tu lo schiacci spara un tot di
lacrime
però io con lui all osso quindi spara le
ossa si farà le ossa madonna che danno
fa è incredibilmente fortissimo tra
l'altro ho tratto un oggetto fortissimo
a caso che culo ci siano raga the boss
dai non ho preso l'altro occhio
ok
madonna è disintegrata in quanto raga
mila gara switcher sa che è normale
perché quando succede ora co demonio
prendo dandomi sa non ho preso la è
uscito satana
vediamo cosa da non male sai però non lo
posso prendere il posto di questo signor
basse che è troppo forte
quindi domandare di sotto nessuna satana
poi del m po incazzata mancano tre piani
ragazzi e 123 del frontline abbiamo
subito diretti dovrebbe essere di sopra
perché la mappa si sviluppa di sopra
credo che satana sia vicino non lo so
non ne sono convintissimo ies è il
momento
quest'uomo è un disastro
ok per la sede calme ragazzo
ok ci siamo
l'haka sono un deficiente
non devo mai stati davanti non so perché
l'ho fatto ok
che sfiga ok bau bau è che palle ok
allora il tabù mi ha sbloccato degli
umbri
il boss più forte del gioco ma l'ho già
battuto con lui
andiamo a fare del m
il secondo bossi prima abbiamo fatto
hanno sbloccato point irib
abbiamo le icone che mancano sono quella
a destra e quella in basso a sinistra
quella in basso al centro è un'altra
modalità ok queste quella porta rim e
gasata sia appena aperta ma se io entro
lì dentro poi non posso fare the lamb
quindi devo assolutamente fare prima del
m poi entrare dalla casata contrario ok
non mi ha creato un sacco di con i
clinici quindi sfruttiamo il nostro gago
ok vediamo nostro personaggio grigio per
fare danno che le scopo ho appena detto
di sfruttare quello grigio estro
sfruttandolo normale poi grazie grazie
questo in cambio di chiariti da oggetti
incredibile a quanto pare va bene
quella è la perla di mamma ti dà più
possibilità di trovare credo cuori grigi
che a me non me ne frega niente amore di
una cagata mi pare di sì mi ha peccato
ok madonna leggo un sacco di più con
quell'oggetto che ho trovato era lì era
la lama di super meat boy se ci avete
fatto caso perché i creatori di questo
gioco sono gli stessi anche di super
meat boy o almeno il designer non mi
dicono che abbiamo trovato un miliardo
di cuori quindi posso andare anche con
lui che con the forgotten e senza
l'anima e va bene uguale
ok questo il boss pino utile di isaac
non serve a niente fa schifo lo batte
anche mia nonna sarebbe stato bellissimo
prender danno quando ho detto sta cagata
qua ragazzi ci siamo sei anni forse o
forse no questo è il fungo power up che
stavo dicendo guardate conto mia mente
all'anno giusto per che tantissimo ma
vela aumenta perché era già alto non è
che ti amo e non è che ti ha da zero che
aumenta quell'anno lì semplicemente
perché era già estremamente alto e
quindi verrà aumentato in una maniera
esponenziale
questo mi rigorosa fa cai ok va bene
cornice va benissimo
nice va bene the lamb e gli altri stage
grazie mamma per la mano
ha preso danno moon pirla quando ti
spara ste robe tu puoi metterti dietro
il tuo corpo perché il tuo corpo ti para
dall'eroe guardate le mega utile contro
è però se io mi metto giustamente non mi
pare ma sono io stupido e sono io che
sono stupido non è colpa sua
allora ho preso danno forse anche con
grigio sempre allora manca solo mega
satana delirium l'ho già fatto quindi
non so se lo rifaccio no perché ci metto
un po non fanno bene cosa poi vedo
ma vediamo se riesco ad andare dove che
è la stanza iniziale mi ricordo dove
equa ok ragazzi il mega satana time devo
prendere prima però i cuori e il momento
di mega satana si parte
ok
i ragazzi allora vegas atene fatto fasi
cioè tutti lui tiltu romeni e poi ti
evoca gente e tu devi fare la gente
fuori la gente che evoca questo qua lo
faccio poi subito che è un fastidio che
non vi dico no no totoro dillo mi basta
una malata e passa subito alla fase
successiva c'è veramente incredibile
ragazzi levo un'infinità ve lo assicuro
chi gioca ad aisa chissà che una build
pazzesca questa peccato che tiro botte
lentamente sono quello solo quella una
rottura di cazzi non ho capito cosa è
successo
ok bene buono
angelo time angelo mio amico a noi
ragazzi l'ho distrutto
ho preso danno peccato perché finora era
senza prendere danno peccato ho preso di
nuovo danno
l'ultima fase ragazzi è una cagata
mostruosa e questa però mi sa che due
volte finito posso mettermi dietro al
mio personaggio e non dovrebbe neanche
beccarmi teoricamente forse perché mi
pare proprio il mio personaggio
veramente utile stata una ragazza
ed errigo ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi
mamma ragazzi abbiamo fatto una
bellissima ranno li ho fatti tutti e tre
quelli che dovevo fare
abbiamo fatto veramente tutto amia spa
che tutelava allora adesso ho fatto
praticamente il mio isaac si presenta
così partiamo dalle guide formate manca
solo quello in basso
vedete l'icona sono tutte tranne con il
basso che la grid che questa modalità
che un'altra qui non la potevo fare
insieme a questi poi ho fatto tutto
praticamente tranne dell'host che queste
persone dobbiamo prendere una botta sola
e muore è praticamente impossibile
signori questa è la novità hi sun è
stato molto divertente da me è piaciuto
tantissimo e stata una bella era un
peccato che sparava lento ma mi sono
divertito un sacco
signori spero vi sia piaciuto subito
bisogno il momento è un mi piace anche a
risorse alcun minuto dall estinzione se
non sapresti schiette e noi come sempre
ci vediamo al prossimo video non trovo
il telecomando ma ecco qui un bacino da
ragazzi
[Musica]